New York has a brand  and when people see it  it means something  you know when we go there it's not  Kansas doesn't have a brand  when you go there yo Okay you're from  Kansas no well you know what  I didn't think it'd be possible for New  York to elect a mayor who's a bigger  douchebag than Bill de Blasio like it  just didn't seem possible I'm the  biggest douche on the planet now Eric  Adams he's not as sort of lumbering and  Goofy he doesn't he doesn't look like  Gumby had a baby with Rex Ryan like uh  like Bill de Blasio does but he's he's  really up there as far as being a tool  New York has a brand I agree by the way  New York does have a brand  the brand is uh here's New York's brand  unlivable overpriced Apple that's that's  New York's brand